more than three months after the corona
virus outbreak the city at the original
epicenter is standing down some of its
medical teams China's National Health
Commission says all critically ill
patients in Wuhan have recovered with
the last group dispatched from hospital
on Saturday oh-hoh will be the number of
patients in severe in critical condition
in Wuhan City finally became zero which
marks a decisive victory in the battle
against the virus and means that the
covert 19 treatment in China has reached
international advanced levels the
government is now focusing its efforts
on a rise in imported cases in the
northern province of Heilongjiang which
borders Russia China has recorded more
than 83,000 cases of the virus but a
study published in the journal Lancet
says the numbers could be four times
higher if they were just presenting with
cold symptoms at a time of winter in
China then they simply would have got
infected thought they had the cold maybe
being diagnosed with having the cold or
pneumonia like symptoms and then gotten
better we're talking about 85% of cases
Singapore now has the highest corona
virus infection rate in Asia it's
reported another spike in its daily
cases the majority of new infections are
migrant workers living in crowded
dormitories medical teams have been
deployed to step up testing and health
checks and the government has extended
the nationwide lockdown until June but
as Singapore tightens its quarantine
measures Vietnam is starting to lift its
restrictions the streets in Hanoi are
still empty but some shops are reopening
for business with the Health Authority
they're reporting no new cases this week
I observed that the government's
decision in strategy are very well
thought-out in logical and in recent
days the outbreak has been pushed back I
feel grateful for being a Vietnamese
citizen it's a downward trend being
shared in South Korea which suffered the
first major outbreak outside China its
government has outlined a two-year
recovery plan after reporting the lowest
number of cases since the peak in
February but the South Korean Health
Minister has warned citizens to accept
the reality that life won't returned to
normal
some time yet Sara Clark al-jazeera